the contributor former Speaker of the
House Newt Gingrich along with North
Carolina Congressman Dan Bishop is with
us all right Mr Speaker you said this is
a win for McCarthy he just tweeted out
as the largest cut in history uh let's
get your take on it
well look I think it's pretty
straightforward if you look at where we
were going which was the Biden position
of no Amendments of any kind no
negotiations just keep raising the debt
ceiling keep go business as usual and
you look where over 100 days the House
Republicans who shocked the country by
actually passing a bill that had real
change real reform real cuts the truth
is we are not nearly as well off as we'd
like to be because we didn't have a
Republican president to negotiate with
but we're dramatically better off than
we would have been if we just rolled
over for Joe Biden so the question I
think for republicans and probably where
Congressman bishop and I have the
deepest disagreement is the consequence
of a no vote I believe having done this
as you know in my new book a March the
majority where I explain how we spent
four years negotiating with Bill Clinton
getting to the only four years of a
balanced budget in your lifetime we did
it one step at a time well this is the
first step now Republicans can decide
it's a pretty reasonable First Step not
everything they want but it starts the
game towards the balanced budget towards
Appropriations this fall remember
to say establish a ceiling not a
basement so he's equipped from the
ceiling down further
is it fair to say then that you believe
based on your experience and you were
the last speaker to balance the budget
to your credit I give you a lot of
credit for that
um that it has to be a process that in
reality it's a process what if the
Republicans just stood firm on their
debt ceiling increase that the CBO
scored out of 4.8 trillion in savings
over 10 years what would have happened
then and then we'll get to the
congressman
Biden would have said no the financial
markets would have collapsed the
Republicans would have been crowded into
position where 20 or 30 of them would
have joined the Democrats and six or
eight of them would have join the
Democrats in the Senate and you would
have a debt ceiling with no cuts no
changes no reforms this is this is chess
this is not Checkers it's not
Tic-tac-toe and you've got to think
through not just one step but five six
or eight or ten steps and in that
consequence I think that Kevin McCarthy
got a pretty good deal and most
importantly he shifted the balance of
power and the balance of leadership away
from both the Senate and the White House
and that is frankly a historic
experience comparable to what we did in
yeah and then you know well I mean
remember Biden started out saying he
wouldn't compromise at all and then went
missing in action for 97 days let's get
your take on the bill
well I agree with former speaker
Gingrich to a point that is to say that
the bill that Republicans passed on the
floor of the house with 218 votes was a
great bill and we were unified in doing
it I know something about that we
created the unity when we went through
the speakers fight in January the
problem is that when speaker McCarthy
entered into this negotiation he gave up
the farm
uh speaker Gingrich describes a bunch of
benefits we've spoken earlier about this
when he when he wrote an article in on
Fox news about it and listed a lot of
these things when you read the text of
the bill they're not there
um the the CBO just today this afternoon
released information an estimate about
the so-called work requirements that
were added to food stamps and to and to
temporary assistance for needy families
they've said that because of the
additional categories of exemptions that
were added in the language of the bill
the cost of the is going to go up by 2.1
billion dollars that's not a get that is
a that that's in fact so in case after
case speaker's team has come out and
told us that we taught touted benefits
when you read the language of the bill
they're not there I was just in the
conference earlier this evening and uh
Mr McCarthy's negotiator talked about
the provision on the IRS taking that 80
you know it turns out to be 1.4 billion
not 1.9 as they claimed but it doesn't
do anything to stop them from hiring
staff with the remaining 78.6 billion
hiring new IRS agents this year now you
know Mister let me ask the speaker about
that if you don't mind Congressman you
know that was a big promise of the
Republicans to to defund the hiring or
the doubling of the IRS agents why
didn't they hold the line or that on
that and I don't think it was
unreasonable the Republicans to say
we're going to go back to 2023 spending
levels with a one percent Baseline
budgeting cap to me they were reasonable
provisions and I can understand people's
anger at that because that seemed the
IRS in particular seem to be a big issue
for Republicans uh Mr Speaker well as I
understand it and I went back I thought
Congressman Bishop was very effective on
your show this afternoon so effective
that I went back to the speaker's staff
and talked to them about several of
these issues and all I can report to is
for this year they don't have the money
to hire the additional agents and this
fall in the Appropriations Bill
Republicans will have upper every
opportunity to continue that process
again this is a one year this is a
process the question is will we be
stronger coming out of this in
continuing to cut out the IRS agents
always be legal I'm told by the way that
a number of Democrats are so shaken by
the cut in domestic discretionary
spending that they're talking about
taking away 20 or 30 billion dollars of
the IRS money to to put it to other
priorities that they think are a lot
more important so I think you've got to
be you know there are a lot of details
here and I think each side has a
different version of what the details
mean but I would suggest to you that
each of these steps as small as they are
are in fact steps away from bigger
spending you've had the New York Post
The Wall Street Journal I mean hardly
left-wing institutions both have said
this is a significant step in the right
direction they have technical experts at
least as good as Congressman bishop and
they have looked at it and they've
concluded that on balance this is a
significant step away from bigger
government not a victory by itself if
you said to me is this the end game I'd
say vote no if you say to me this is the
first step I would say vote Yes
Dan Sean Sean I really can't believe my
ears when when folks tell me well it
doesn't matter if it's not in the
language of the bill what are they
saying they've got a handshake agreement
with Joe Biden I mean I can't believe
that but here's the real here's the real
killer
it took the debt ceiling out to the
January 1 2025 a year longer than the
Republican bill proposed here's a piece
of information for your viewers I just
heard it tonight from the speaker in the
conference he said the reason that
happened was his call
it wasn't even asked for by the
Democrats he didn't want to end up in
another negotiation with Joe Biden next
year because he believed that they would
ask for more
that's what he said I that's you
understand that's a 4 trillion maybe
five or six trillion dollar increase in
debt
that we just let him have and the
speaker says he made the call I don't
understand that and and it just it
doesn't make sense it is if it it
fractured Republican Unity that was so
hard won we're going to have to figure
out how to put that back together I
don't know what happens with this
Congressman Wisconsin with Democrat
votes now you talked earlier about the
need maybe for a motion to vacate when
when Kevin McCarthy became speaker uh
that was an issue any one member can
basically call for this no confidence
vote and the speaker you said earlier
today that's under consideration you
believe that's going to happen
what I said Sean is I it seems
inescapable to me given what has
occurred and the way he was the steward
of Republican unity and he blew it to
Smithereens but there was a sort of one
report that said you would be the guy
that did it is that true that's not how
I said it uh and I'm not I don't go off
doing things like that half cocked or
for my own personal interest or out of
any animus there are people that very
serious people we worked with very hard
you know Sean speaker Gingrich was a
Critic you were a Critic of us in
January but the result we achieved
actually I wasn't a Critic I didn't mind
the process I just thought you guys
should have done it earlier I mean that
should have happened and we should have
been ready to hit the ground running was
my argument just to be clear Point Sean
the point Sean is that we we we actually
achieved something that that almost
shocked the country in that process and
the unity that was won so that we could
put this bill on the floor and pass it
when people said we're too fractious to
do it they were wrong and and why would
you go into a negotiation without
calling folks on something that
fundamental
and and blow up the unity I understand
speaker again
what look I'm not trying to interrupt
you the congressman I want to be fair to
both sides here Congressman what seems
to be lacking in this and I may be wrong
is as the speaker was negotiating with
the White House it sounds like he was
not communicating with his caucus and
and it seems to me that that needed to
be a big part of the process especially
when you take into account that the the
margin of Republicans majority is so
small
because I wasn't part of that process
but I'll say this
having I think pretty successfully
negotiated with Bill Clinton for four
years and having produced welfare reform
the largest capital gains tax cut in
history and the only four consecutive
balanced budgets in your lifetime
I actually think there's a lot of wisdom
in saying to people you wouldn't
necessarily win a second round on the
debt ceiling next year which you can win
I say is to all the conservatives you
think you can win you're going to have a
whole series of Appropriations bills
this fall Congressman Massey got
introduced and then McCarthy got adopted
a provision that if the Congress doesn't
pass all their Appropriations bills
there's an automatic for all government
cut in spending so there's a huge
incentive to get this done uh and my
point would be guys
the the conservatives have lots of
opportunities in the next year and a
half to make their case uh but to do
that the stronger they are the more
unified they look and the greater the
degree that what the House Republicans
become the center of gravity the better
off we are and if this bill goes down
don't kid yourself well you're going to
get out of that is a clean sea debt
ceiling with no reforms because people
will crumble under the way to the
financial community and the fear of a
deficit the United States defaulting and
so I think there's a this is a huge
gamble to decide that a no vote is
acceptable all right Congressman I'll
give you 20 seconds I'm way over time
here
thanks Sean look the the problems are
what are not in the bill speaker
Gingrich just referred to another one
there is no Auto CR in the bill there is
a one percent reduction but that that's
that it you just and and and he's also
right that we can't get in a position
where we're split apart and and you end
up with a with a clean ceiling that goes
on forever but we'll you know that's why
this has to be better operated we'll fix
it but I'm not sure how right now all
right thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else